الان من امام مجمع الشفاء الطبي في مدينه
غزه معتصم صلاح عضو لجنه الطوارئ في وزاره
الصحه نرحب به ولكن قبل ان نبدا في
المقابله دعني فقط انوه الى هذا الخبر
العاجل الذي يظهر الان على شاشتنا حزب
الله يقول استهدفنا تجمعا لجنود العدو في
ثكنه هنين
بالاسلحه المناسبه وهذا ما جاء اذا عن حزب
الله اذا سيد معتصم صلاح المعارك تشتد
القصف يستمر واعداد
الضحايا الى ارتفاع انتم في لجنه الطوارئ
ما اخر ما تقوله تقاريركم وكيف تتعاملون
مع هذه
الظروف نعم خلال ال 24 ساعه الماضيه حتى
هذه اللحظه وصل الى مجمع الشفاء الطبي
اكثر من 70 شهيد واكثر من 130 جريح نعم
حاول جاهدين التعامل مع هذا العدد الكبير
من الاصابات في ظل عدم القدره على تشغيل
كل المنظومه الصحيه بعد استهداف كافه
المستشفيات في محافظه غزه وشمال قطع غزه
نحاول جاهدين حاليا فتح مجموعه من غرف
العمليات في المستشفيات الاهليه من خلال
اشراف وزاره الصحه ودعم هذه المؤسسات
والمستشفيات بكل الاحتياجات اللازمه ايضا
في داخل مجمع الشفاء الطبي
انتهينا من التجهيزات النهائيه لفتح ثلاث
غرف عمليات من اجل التعامل مع الجرحى
الذين هم بحاجه لاجراء عمليات طارئه ولكن
المشهد معقد حتى غرف العمليات والقدره
السريريه محدوده امام عدد الجرحى الكبير
امام الحالات الجرحى والمصابين المعقده
التي بحاجه الى اكثر من عمليه جراحيه في
ان واحد في ظل عدد
الاخصائيين القليل جدا بعد ذهاب وتهديد
كافه الطواقم الصحيه بالتوجه الى جنوب
قطاع غزه نحن مستمرون في اداء رسالتنا
الانسانيه والمهنيه والاخلاقيه امام شعبنا
وسنحاول فتح مزيد من الخدمات ايضا فيما
يتعلق بالنازحين
واماكن تجمع مجموعه من الاصابي الذين
غادروا المستشفيات قمنا بانشاء مجموعه من
النقاط الطبيه ايضا للتخفيف الضغط على
المستشفيات والاقسام التي نقوم ب فتحها من
خلال متابعه هؤلاء الجرحى
واعطائهم العلاجات والرعايه الطبيه
اللازمه لكن بكل
امانه الحاجه امام هذا العدد الكبير من
الجرحى وما نقوم به من جهود هي جهود
متواضعه وقليله امام الحاجه الكبيره امام
هؤلاء الجرحى وهي جهود بالتاكيد مقدره
وكبيره وفق هذه الظروف المشهد معقد مثل ما
قلت حدثنا اكثر عن عمل الطواقم الطبيه بعد
كل ما تعرض له مستشفى الشفاء ومثل ما تحتد
الدكتور اشرف القدره قبل قليل عن استمرار
اعتقال
مدير المستشفى
والاحتياجات التي يبقى المستشفى في امس
الحاجه لها هو وباقي مستشفيات
القطاع
يعني مجمع الشفاء الطبي لكي نقوم باعاده
تشغيله نحن بحاجه الى مجموعه كثيره من
المتطلبات والاحتياجات لاعاده تشغيل مجمع
الشفاء الطبي اول هذه الاحتياجات اللي
الموجوده هي عوده الطواقم الصحيه المتخصصه
غالبيه الكوادر الصحيه من الاخصائيين من
مختلف الجراحات هم موجودين ومتواجدين في
في جنوب قطاع غزه ما يتم اجراءه حتى في
المستشفيات التي التي تم فتحها هي فقط
عمليات جراحيه للجراحه العامه للجراحه
العظام لكن باقي التخصصات الطبيه كافه
الاخصائيين المتواجدين في جنوب غزه لذا
نطالب بعوده كافه الكوادر الصحيه من اجل
اعاده تشغيل هذه المستشفى ثاني الاحتياجات
هناك حاجه ماسه لادخال وعاده وصيانه كافه
الانظمه التشغيليه في داخل مجمع الشفاء
الطبي اغلب الانظمه التشغيل
تم اعطا بها وهناك حدث خلل كبير جدا في
العديد من الانظمه وبالتالي نحن نحتاج الى
قطع الغيار اللازمه وللاجهزه والمعدات من
اجل اعاده تشغيل محطه
الاكسجين تم تشغيل جزء من هذه المحطه وبعض
المحطات في داخل بعض مدينه غزه لكن محطات
الاكسجين محطات والانظمه
التشغيليه بحاجه الى ايضا الى تشغيل اذا
تحدثت عن اجهزه التعقيم هي بحاجه ولقسم
التعقيم هو بحاجه الى
مياه
حلوه لكي تعمل هذه الاجهزه حتى مياه الشرب
لا تتوفر ادنى المقومات الاساسيه غير
متوفره لذا نحن بحاجه الى ايضا كل
الاحتياجات الاساسيه لم اتحدث عن الادويه
والمستهلكات الطبيه وقائمه من الاجهزه
والمعدات ايضا هناك حاجه كبيره ومشهد معقد
مث ل ما ق
فق نعم نشكرك جزيل الشكر عذرا انتهت وقت
انتهى وقت المقابله معتصم صلاح عضو لجنه
الطوارئ في وزاره الصحه حدثنا من امام
مجمع الشفاء الطبي في مدينه
غزه